[Music]
if you haven't done so already set up
your project and create a google cloud
storage bucket in the cloud console on
the project select your page select or
create a cloud project make sure that
billing is enabled for your google cloud
project learn how to confirm billing is
enabled for your project in the links
below enable the cloud vision API
you
now create a cloud storage bucket in the
cloud console go to the cloud storage
browser page click create bucket assign
a unique bucket name do not include
sensitive information in the bucket name
because the bucket name space is global
and publicly visible select the location
where the bucket data will be stored for
default storage class select standard
then click create now you can make
requests via the vision API download
this demo image linked below
open the cloud console storage browser
select the bucket you just created click
upload files and select the demo image
JPEG file to upload from your local
machine to your cloud storage bucket
after the file is uploaded and listed in
the cloud storage browser share the
image publicly
you
open the interactive API Explorer
template found in the guide linked below
complete the template by replacing cloud
samples data slash vision in the image
source image URI field with the name of
the cloud storage bucket where you
uploaded the demo image JPEG file click
execute to send the request to the
service
the Jayson response appears here
congratulations you've just made your
first images annotate request to the
cloud vision API service to learn more
about specific features see example
annotations and get annotations for an
individual file or image check out the
cloud documentation
[Music]